now just to tie this up in a bit of a
bow I'd love you to draw a a bit of a
table we've need tables going to need
three columns we'll ignore the first
color for a second the second column
will be change of scale the third column
will change of origin and then what
we're going to do is think about the
effect of this on each of the things
that we calculated so there's going to
be expected value how does that change
there's going to be variance how does
that change and then there's going to be
standard deviation how does that change
okay so this is what our table is
roughly going to look like
okay huh I can move again that's nice
so here's what this looks like let's
fill this in we started off with change
of scale we were thinking about what
happens if you change from meters to
centimeters but you could change for
anything right you could go from like
miles to kilometers or you could go from
mils - that's not a good example
oh yeah mils two liters or something
like that right in other words your data
stays essentially the same but your
scale of your graph changes your numbers
are all in like huge numbers or small
numbers etc so as an example let's
consider what we did before our example
was instead of having X maybe we have
100x that's what we did when we changed
from meters to centimeters okay what
happened to our expected value we made
all our data a hundred times bigger so
what happened to your expected value
also 100 times bigger right so a hundred
X if you've got a change of 100 X you
expect the value also goes up by 100 at
times right but your variance your
variance did not right did you notice
that your variance it changed in
proportion to not 100 but 100 squared
very good so in our case that was 10,000
right but then to get from variance to
standard deviation what change did we
make what's the single operation you do
to get from various standard deviation
take the square root so it overcomes
this squaring change you get back to
whatever factor you introduced okay
whatever fat you introduced okay so
that's what happens when you make your
data bigger or smaller right and that's
just with this particular example then
the last thing we did was what happens
if you change the origin where do you
start measuring from so there's some
constant that you add to every score or
some constant that you subtract from
every score what were the things that we
noticed about the expected value if for
example if for example we said are X and
then we subtracted what was it point o2
two centimetres because we're in
millimeters in meters right so what
happened to the expected value how did
it change I mean it's it changed by this
exact same factor did you agree if we
had added something like if I decided oh
I'm just gonna make all of you taller it
would also have gotten taller right
so therefore this change is identical
right but then what did you notice about
variance and standard deviation when you
move everyone together how does the
spread of the data change it did it
change it didn't change our numbers are
all the same on the spreadsheet right so
you would say here there's no change no
change at all in other words you're just
back at X right it's the same deal here
no change you're just back at X okay so
to show you how we can use this right
can you turn in your booklet if you
haven't gotten out already go ahead turn
to page 46 page 46
once you get to pitch 46 is a discrete
random variable there and we're gonna
have a look at how it changes this is
question 23 booklets booklets good okay
fantastic 20 are 46 46 yes
okay so I have a look at the question
you can see there's some data there
there's the discrete random variable in
the table there you can see that data
and then they say calculates instead of
the expected value of this or the
variance of this they say calculate the
expected value of this now what does
this mean okay
it means two things there's a change of
scale that happens and there's a change
of origin the change of scale is
whatever the new scale is it's going to
be twice as big yeah that make sense
that's why there's the true there and we
also are going to shift all the values
down so our origin where we begin
measuring from it also changes okay now
we've got two options for how we can do
this okay we can do the spreadsheet
route right do you mem what we did we
took every piece of data and then we
like multiply two by 100 and then we
just recalculate we just got Excel to do
all the grunt work right but now that we
know all of this we can kind of just
work out the expected value as it is and
then make the adjustments necessary so
let's start off by doing that let's work
out the regular expected value and get
from there to here I'll show you how to
do it we need the expected value first
so you'll need your calculator there
we're gonna add up it's always
probability x value probability x values
so let's go ahead and do this you're
gonna have to do a bit of crunching with
me what are we going
do you put a 5 fantastic okay like
saying all right so before we move on to
variance we will get to that in a second
we actually already have all we need to
go from here to here right yeah we could
do it in Excel but in fact because we've
done the work in Excel we can apply that
knowledge here without needing to go to
a spreadsheet so we can just do it
without brain it's not complicated right
have a look at my row here I'm looking
at expected value right so this expected
value here is 2x minus 4 right is
expected value changed by the change of
scale it is right and it's changed
exactly in proportion to however much
your scale changes right is expected
value also changed by the change of
origin the answer is yes it will change
by exactly the amount that you move it
up or down okay so therefore this is
equal to double right that expected
value that we started with right just
like we multiplied it and then what's
the other thing we do we're not going to
subtract point o2 we're going to
subtract in this case 4 that's how much
they've changed about right so this is
double two point eight five take away
four do we have an answer five sorry one
point seven yeah because 5.7 take away
four okay yep
yeah yeah that's five point seven take
away four gives me one point seven okay
now
is just thinking you were thinking the
steps through yeah it's fine you're like
5.7 take away 4 1.7 ok now if you like
you can actually take this data here you
can pop it into that spreadsheet that we
created and you will be able to verify
this is totally fine right